hello and welcome to this video to Grand
Master black coffee who is that there is
no name okay so maybe i can get my funky
attacking line going no not with this
war it's a bit of a shame i always like
to get that in yeah yeah i don't have
such an attractive line ready I can play
the same stuff still Bishop c5 no
problem the look was far less aggressive
him compared to the line where then
cancelling is delayed and age five
becomes quite serious option so here on
Heba probably plays Knight to g5 yeah I
had something like that 2792 bishop 8395
was an extremely annoying no is it that
annoying okay 27 that I cannot be sad
that bad nightly tool Bishop late no
Isis doing that okay I that make sense
of preparing Bishop to h1 what about 94
m playing away actually I'm is there
something no
I know Nigel is that this is an
extremely that's very casement style but
I really have a soft spot for those
cavemen move sometimes and now at five
is that is that completely naive my
attacking player maybe it is but f4 f4
looks kind of dangerous sometimes the
white clay in in this English lines
English like it is sometimes a bit too
sophisticated I'm not sure if this is
the case here but I had the same thing
myself playing wide and you play those
there was a sophisticated maneuvers and
and whatever and then all of a sudden
and the other guy just swings the hammer
and was dead okay so f for supplying and
I'm not going to refrain from that I
mean accident feels really dangerous to
me maybe he plays he takes at four he
takes at four and then T for that
certainly is coming into consideration
and no 95 well here I will probably take
and don't from there and look that I
feel as interesting is easy for just to
make sure he didn't block my bishop so
easily with default this is not easy to
do anyway so I'm probably just going to
double use all the pieces yes that was
to be expected the thing is if I take he
still has this issue on that diagonal
and he has a7d for diagonal
let's double first yep key place again
all those sophisticated moves but we'll
see only like I take yes to take with
the depot and he covers the night just
about
quite tough yeah I can play something
like that same night to d8 and then make
c 6-r wonder looks a bit slow I mean he
has neither for by the way that to move
that is possible it was possible to move
before yeah i'm basically committed to
two sec to exchange to the exchange tag
but it's not something that i mind all
that much that feels kind of standard 22
sec the exchange here i have or 1296
trying to take with the night down
objectively speaking I'm probably in
trouble but it is still quite quite a
messy position how to talk to time gonna
do that now takes a diagonal is
extremely weak okay I think I'll do this
first then yes we've got some checks now
like he and maybe time morning maybe a
queen on the light squares by Bishop
here really sucks Jim not good okay naw
Dee he defended as well I'm I'm really
not sure but I thought at the beginning
of all that I felt I had a fairly good
to the good position okay now i have to
trade and share that's the thing my
bishop is the worst piece ever and it's
got ok eight coming
we really feel like it was good for
black it looked very dangerous anyway so
I have two real money originally it
feels him defendant as well and at the
beginning of that certainly that looks
dangerous to me the computer is not
Amina kate is not really all that deep
now with 18 Devon doesn't it doesn't see
anything ever hears it sees a black we
know actually so we have seven so I'm
winning here but I didn't okay so i
should i should avoid the capture all I
shouldn't want to capture help how bad
is that and threatening efore bloody
destroyed that that's the winner already
oh my god yeah this is a lot better and
I don't have the e file open for his car
looks lame okay so that was the key
moment interesting when the engine gives
some weird remove and now night is seven
complete raiding his best piece and then
going for I mean you you have no well
your king is really in trouble here so
that was so charity so this was a
mistake I was thinking that I have this
that I should take to actually weaken
default it really isn't the case yeah
this this was was already putting me
into trouble I can still take and be
okay to be sick simply prying this
opening yet the big opportunity was
about to take him clearly that was
stronger I mean yeah I don't necessarily
need to lose but channels now
okay he defended okay after I've played
this panel hi okay thanks for watching